hey youtubers is Charlie so a bunch of
you guys last night requested a Superman
black costume video just because people
think that they may have seen another
look from behind the scenes Warner
Brothers typically doesn't comment on
stuff like this and it may be fake it
looks like a very convincing fake if it
is but I wanted to explain the black
costume from the comics because there's
a long history of him wearing it in all
the Justice League prequel scenes that
set up his return because even just in
the couple of movies that we've seen so
far we've seen him come back to life so
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so this is really cool but a
lot of people think that this is fake so
just you know pending official
confirmation we just had to take it both
ways but the reason why people think
that he's wearing a black suit at some
point in the movie is because he was
buried in his black Kryptonian suit in
the comics the original suit as you can
see was just torn to shreds in his fight
with doomsday the same thing happened
after Superman's fight with doomsday in
Batman vs Superman
and if you remember all of the
Kryptonians wear black Under Armour like
that's their version of underwear that
they walk around in that Superman's
costume was colored blue to look like so
there's actually a lot of black
Kryptonian suits that are left on earth
after all this Kryptonian stuff in the
Man of Steel movie in esthetically
they've been pretty true to the comic so
I'll explain the black suit from the
comics as well as the return of Superman
in the movies they've already given us
all the evidence that we need and the
synopsis for Justice League that tees up
some of the mother box threat from dark
side they basically act like beacons
that alert darks eyes minions and
Steppenwolf to what's going on on earth
so that sort of tees up the events of
Justice League which obviously gives
Batman the nightmares that we saw during
Batman vs Superman so we got like a
couple really key scenes as well as the
comic book black suit stuff so far the
only confirmed new Hardcore suit that
we've seen is from Batman just because
of this increased threat even the
Batmobile gets juiced up to fight
parademons the actual synopsis tell
a little bit about how crazy the threat
is going to be so it explains why some
of them are wearing more hardcore suits
but it says fueled by his restored faith
in humanity and inspired by Superman's
selfless act Bruce Wayne and lists the
help of his newfound Ally Diana Prince
to face an even greater enemy together
Batman and Wonder Woman work quickly to
find and recruit a team of metahumans
which we also here to stand against a
newly awakened threat which makes you
think about the mother boxes alerting
them to their presence on earth but
despite the formation of this
unprecedented League of Heroes using
very special language there Batman
Wonder Woman Aquaman cyborg in the flash
it may already be too late to save the
planet from an assault of catastrophic
proportions so you basically have
Batman's nightmare slowly coming true
albeit in a slightly different way so
this is that Batman V Superman scene
where the parademons rush him so just
imagine a version of this without the
Superman symbolism here
[Applause]
now what does that synopsis tell you it
tells you the Superman is not a rat like
he isn't in any of the promo material
even though he was in the
behind-the-scenes teaser that they
released a while ago where they're
filming the movie wearing his blue
costume hardcore comic book fans will
notice that he does not have a mullet in
this picture so either he's gotten a
haircut or there will be no mullet the
reason for the mullet in the comics is
just because this was a 90s thing that
was a 90s hairstyle so Superman dies the
Eradicator steals his body and starts
bombarding him with solar energy to try
and bring him back overloads it and
blows up the system but he returns but
in that time span his hair has grown out
so he just rolls with the new haircut he
was meant to be sort of a redesign for
the character
so just to tee this up in the movies
we've already seen a couple of scenes
that had told us how he's coming back so
I'm going to play like this last little
scene so we'll talk about the return of
Superman and how that worked out in the
comics he's a slightly different story
where the black costume comes from so
the funny thing about that scene it's
really just intended to tell you that
Superman is slowly coming back to life
they had that scene where he got noot
earlier in the film with his fight with
doomsday where the Sun heals him that
was all intended to sort of tee data to
let you know hey sunlight makes him
better he could come back from a
near-death experience or even death
itself just as long as he gets sunlight
solar radiation from our Yellow Sun so
buried in the coffin underneath the
ground he was getting very very little
solar energy it just takes a long time
for his body to heal so the dust it's
like slowly rising off the coffin here
doesn't totally make sense because
Superman doesn't levitate things around
him he levitates himself but I think the
explanation here is that when he flies
like this was getting you know hardcore
technical explanation here when he flies
there's just like a small field around
his body that allows him like a certain
measure of tactic Kinesis but it's not
like he's telekinetic Superman's had a
lot of crazy
powers in the classic comics but in the
modern continuity they tried to be a
little more simple about it the point is
is that they just want to let you know
the Superman is coming back but it's not
going to happen til the next movie you
know very ambiguous about the timing of
when he's coming back
but because Kryptonian science is still
very new to the earth nobody knows about
this so Batman thinks he's dead Wonder
Woman thinks he's dead even though she's
seen a lot of things she said she's
killed things that are not from this
earth so it was kind of surprised when
she just bought Superman's death face
value but when you look at this suit
it's way more hardcore than the black
comic-book suit which itself is also
just a standard Kryptonian suit that he
wears it's almost like Kryptonian under
armor if you remember from the Man of
Steel movie they kind of tuned the
colors down so it's hard to tell but
they all wear suits like that underneath
their regular armor back during Man of
Steel when he found that first
Kryptonian ship it gave him the Superman
costume the blue ones that he wore in
that first movie the ship itself made
the costume it is sort of like a
made-to-order thing based on jor-el
specifications in Superman's input so in
the way that Lex tries to tap into the
Kryptonian ship and learn things people
can use Kryptonian technology but as of
the beginning of Batman vs Superman
there was like a prequel comic where you
learn that even Bruce Wayne's company
has been studying Kryptonian technology
so even if the ship was blown up as
Superman just can't fabricate anything
he wants anymore there's other ways to
adapt Kryptonian technology to help him
out and I think that we're headed for a
venture will for trous of solitude in
the movies but maybe not till the next
Man of Steel movie which will just
tentatively call the man of tomorrow you
guys let me know if you agree though do
you feel like they're going to leave
Superman out of all the marketing
materials at least the early marketing
materials for Justice League that's
going to be ramping up later this year
but I feel like they still want to have
an element of surprise even though the
producers have acknowledged that he's
coming back everybody that's ever read a
comic book knows that he's coming back
everybody that saw the movie and stayed
through the end of Batman vs Superman
saw that he's coming back so it's one of
those weird situations where all the
fans are just kind of like sitting there
waiting for something to happen that
they know is going to happen just really
hyped up congratulations to the new
flash ring giveaway winner Christopher
Murray please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what's going to happen
later tonight is I was going to do a
Green Lantern video because they've been
talking about the casting there's a lot
of funny stories behind that Bradley
Cooper audition for the original Green
Lantern and now he's back on their list
so is Ryan Reynolds the big WTF
but because Marvel comics have been
tanking lately everybody feels like
there's going to be a DC style rebirth
for Marvel during infinity war so I'll
do a video for that tonight infinity war
Marvel rebirth and then Green Lantern
tomorrow along with new Game of Thrones
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my breakdown of the
other Justice League costumes they just
showed off you can click here for the
trailer for the next episode of the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
I